okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is council peter richards i'll
be chairing the meeting this evening it
is now six o'clock so we will get
underway um a few housekeeping things to
start with if i may we're not expecting
this to be a fire alarm so if one does
go follow us out to the car park next
the windmill we just need everyone over
there so we can check everyone's got out
the building safely
um if you could please turn your phones
off at the very least to silent i
appreciate sometimes you might need to
use it so if you could turn it to
minimum silent ideally off
um i don't mind using them as long as
they don't disturb the flow and of this
meeting
it is a meeting a public meet sorry a
meeting in public not a public meeting
so only those people that have been
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so uh we are being um recorded sadly
we're not being live streamed we'd have
a bit of a technical glitch this
afternoon uh you can probably see we've
got wires going everywhere um we've done
what we can to make sure everything can
run smoothly so do please bear with us
uh while we do that hopefully everyone
from the public can see the one screen
that we have available um as the
uh as the items go forward if if the
people who are representing on the item
on the screen want to move towards the
front then by all means do so that you
can see
but hopefully we should be okay with the
flow of the meeting
okay let's start introducing some people
so
to my far right we have uh silva jarrett
who is our committee services
representative to my immediate right we
have ross chambers who is our solicitor
um planning uh officers that we have are
stewart flaherty charlotte dix luis
coleman and victoria kempton um we have
charlotte and louise will be joining us
online they will be heard through these
speakers so hopefully you'll all be able
to hear them um and of course we have
dale barker who is our planning manager
dale i believe you have a statement to
me yes thank you chair my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision taking
thank you fabulous thank you very much
um okay let's get into the meeting
proper so apologies for absence please
say
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam crump eden foreman
kendall and mills tonight
okay just a couple thank you very much
um
okay disclosures of interest members i'm
i'm gonna assume that there's a few so
i'm gonna kick off with a couple and
then i'll come to you guys so first of
all application twenty one zero zero
five five seven f u l that is bancroft
gardens um i've certainly received a
number of emails from members of the
public i believe they've been all copied
to you guys just not to heads yep so
we'll do that as a blanket um
uh disclosure and similarly on uh the
second item which is twenty zero zero
one three one ful uh the snitchfield
sports club um again i've received
emails from members of the public and
also from the agent i'm assuming you all
have as well
yes i will also be speaking on that so i
will be removing myself from the chair
and passing over to the more than
capable council of fleming who will take
over for that item and that item only
do we have any other disclosures we'd
like to make councillor jennings please
lovely thank you very much anyone else
no okay marvelous um so we don't have
any minutes to approve so we'll get into
our first item which is application 2100
557 full bancroft gardens
i'm presenting officer stewart fletchy
stuart over to you
thank you chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking full planning
commission for the change of use of a
pedestrian public area to host markets
for up to 43 days of the year
the application site is within the
built-in very boundary of stratfor
panaven uh we are in a waterside town
center location just next to the canal
um
one can see there is a smattering of
listed buildings on this uh plan on your
screens indicated by the red blocks the
closest of which is the encore pub
approximately 20 meters
to the west
we are also within a conservation area
here we see an indicative site layout
plan
provided by the applicant
this illustrates the likely layout of
the markets when they are erected and
other associated development
amongst other constraints on this site
we are also within a flood zone in
addition to being in an air designated
area of restraint
uh here we see some specifications of
the gazebos in question for the markets
um they extend to a height of three
meters and are three meters wide
we now have some photos of the site and
its surroundings um here we are stood on
the highway looking north eastwards in
the direction of both the canal and the
bridge here
um
here we are now stood within the
application site itself looking north
westwards
towards the grade 2 listed encore pub
here and bridge street over here
and finally here we are stood again
within application site this time
looking southwards towards the rsc
theatre
offices are overview that this proposal
for the sighting of temporary markets
aids local commerce and is a benefit
both to the local community and visitors
to the town
uh i refer you all to the update sheet
for a further consultation received um
this week uh chairman the recommendation
is to grant this application for reasons
set out on pages eight and nine of your
agenda thank you
stuart thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker tonight who's mr
kevin bond from the stratford society
good evening
and welcome
now you will see on your desk you've got
some alco gels and some wipes feel free
to use those as you please um once
you've finished if you don't mind giving
the desk a quick wipe down with one of
the wipes to be great in the bin just to
the side of you you'll have three
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
towards the end of your time um and if
you'd say seated questions afterwards
that'd be great otherwise when you're
ready it's over to you thank you i hope
everybody can hear me i'm
come to object on the basis of a number
of points the first
point set of points are contained within
the letters of objection that i've filed
and that is that this council has issued
a number of policies particularly an
area of restraint which is includes the
area which has just been presented
and those policies are very clear that
they are areas of restraint because
development of any type in that area
will harm
the historic
aspects of this town
to my knowledge those policies have not
been withdrawn
secondly an illustration of that is what
you've been shown in the
pictures as wholly misleading because
the indicative layout is not the actual
layout because all of you will be aware
that this is a retrospective application
because this council has permitted uh
transactions and under the town and
country planning act which are not
authorized there is no planning consent
for the market that has been held in
that location on many occasions in the
past few months
so the council is in breach of its own
policies
similarly this council has an
enforcement policy which is published
and well uh well documented
not once has enforcement action been
undertaken against the market operator
is that because this council is in a
contractual undertaking with that market
operator under a contract that was
renewed last year for a further five
years in conjunction with stratford town
council
that
ladies and gentlemen
means that this council is compromised
it cannot act impartially
sorry just bear with me unfortunately
your microphone has just died on us can
you if you turn it off and turn it on
again the old technical yep there we go
so therefore this con this council is in
a fiduciary relationship with with
another party part of that relationship
is to hold a market that market if it's
now a five-year contractual undertaking
cannot be determined as a temporary
market
it is a permanent market on a number of
days in each year
by contract agreed by this council
therefore the application is spurious
i would then move on to make the point
that under your own
guidance
code of cop
30 seconds
and under your own code of conduct you
are barred from officiating in granting
a license where you the council have a
fiduciary relationship that applies to
you both corporately and individually
and if you breach that you will be both
corporately and individually liable to
legal action against you
i would urge you to put aside this
nonsense refer it to an independent
third party who can adjudicate on this
application on the grounds of the
existing policy of this council and on
the fiduciary issues that compromise
independence thank you chairman
thank you very much we have one slightly
over three minutes but we did interrupt
you twice so um that's no problem
members do we have any questions for our
speaker
no in that case mr bond thank you very
much for your time and contribution this
evening
i'll wipe your desk
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed so our next
speaker on this item will be councillor
jennings counseling is going to make way
forward
you know the drill three minutes 30
second warning and stay seated for
questions if you would otherwise when
you're ready
don't think i'll take up the three
minutes i'll be quite brief on this one
and i think thankfully this will be one
of the easier applications for the
committee to consider tonight
whilst there will always be some who
object
to anything to do with the markets the
majority of people are in favor of
markets and see the benefits they bring
stratford is famous for its markets and
they bring in huge numbers into
stratford which supports the local
economy this benefits the whole of the
town
whilst i'm here i might as well go to
boots they go to the market i'll go to
boots i'll go into the one of the other
shops
then when they go into this tank when i
go into town
the money gets spread around it benefits
everyone
covert has meant that there have been no
overseas tourists so they've had to rely
on the domestic tourists so you need a
hook to bring them in and the markets
are one of the major attractions it
supports the whole economy
our markets are professionally run by
lsd who recently picked up one of the
top prizes at the great british market
awards
the market was named the country's best
large specialty market during a ceremony
in birmingham at the national
association of british market authority
awards
it's high-grade stuff
last year dermot who's a director at lsd
was and who is a highly respected
businessman was asked to join the
stratforward bid as a board member he
makes regular contribution to help
stratford
survive and thrive
and you may not know this but like all
businesses they also pay business rates
on the market pitches
waterside is what
council james do you want to grab them
i've stopped you time do you want to
grab the microphone to your right and
we'll dispose of that one
you need might actually turn back on
thank you
it's all going well technically today
yeah is that better that is i'll give
you an extra five seconds so if you
start speaking i'll start the clock
after okay warsaw is where the young
market traders final is held and that's
a major national event a springboard for
new entrepreneurs to test the market
before they all consider getting a
retail unit this is so popular and
successful that the national organizers
have taken the steps not to move it to
oxford birmingham nottingham or
manchester but
but to run it again in stratford
markets raise huge amounts for charities
as well
and the christmas market raised nearly
four and a half thousand for charities
however i suppose i'm not here to talk
about all the great things about which
the markets do i'm here to talk about
material planning matters and obviously
you've all read the papers um so you
know what you know what's in them but to
summarize it um this app this
application conforms to cs1 cs2 cs4 cs6
cs8 cs9 cs15 cs22 cs23 cs24
cs26 30 seconds okay i'll try and get
through then ndp policy be1 ndp policy b
8 ndp policy e3 the ndp policies clw 1 2
and eight sbd parts d and q
and
when you look at all the other statutory
comments
no objections from anyone including the
town council
so and finally they can probably do this
through permitted developments anyway
i'm gonna have to ask you to wrap up
then
okay i therefore ask you to support the
office of recommendation and grant this
planning application
cash ranks thank you very much remember
do you have any questions for council
jennings please council dixon
thank you chairman castle jennings um
we've heard from uh the stratford
society uh that they think there's
probably some legal um irrespective
conditions that basically prevent us
possibly from making the decision this
evening have you heard of the those
arguments being put forward to use to
you as portfolio holder before this
evening and if so have you any response
um no i would suggest that i wouldn't
want to wouldn't want to reply on legal
matters i think we probably best put it
to
thank you to the front yep
council curtis
uh thank you uh thank you uh council
jennings as you um
mentioned i think in your very eloquent
presentation that uh for example people
go to the markets and then they'll go
into boots and were you aware that boots
have actually signed the petition
against this proposal
whenever you get petitions you can
it depends how you present them i've
seen petitions um where people have gone
in they've said they've put it in a way
and that's
if an independent
group did the survey
possibly bless it i don't know i can't
comment i think the answer is no um
ultimately so yeah thank you does anyone
else have any questions for councillor
jennings
no in that case james thank you very
much for your time contribution pleasure
thank you thank you
once cancer jennings has finished wiping
the desk down for us i will call forward
cancer fragility i guess foreign
that microphone isn't broken so you
might want to swap it with the one to
your right but wherever you're
comfortable
yeah temperamental is probably the best
one
i'll switch it out in a second
okay again i think you probably know the
drill you'll have five minutes uh 30
seconds towards the end otherwise the
floor is yours whenever you're ready
have you pressed the button in the
middle
oh listen yeah thank you
um as world councillor for this
contested area
this particular contested area i've been
more
than aware of passionately held conflict
conflicting views
as to how this land should be used and
protected you've heard from mr bond
some of the detail of the deeply held
concerns and you have the written
details in your papers which you have
had time to read carefully
it is a designated open space of
restraint with its own protections but
it has been used as a very busy
unsuccessful market area for most
sundays in every year without proper
consent
an increasing number of other days
saturdays and sometimes weekdays on
separate agreements with sdc
i think there is a concern that the
number of days being used for a market
in this area is having an adverse effect
on businesses
in and around bridge street and sheep
street and i know that a local
resident businessman has actually
visited businesses in this area and i
believe you got
his report of a number of businesses
that are unhappy uh with with the market
on so many days in this particular
position
i don't think these these people are
against well i'm assured that the group
i'm speaking for this evening
have no objection to markets in the town
they see this as a market town but they
would like to see the markets actually
spread further throughout the town to
actually make sure that vibrancy goes up
to the north part of the town the top of
wood street interval the street
which probably needs a little bit more
encouragement into the shops there
because the riverside is all already
a honey pot where people naturally go
and having consistent markets there
actually sort of doubles that attraction
and there's a very strong feeling that
that should be spread further around the
town
i just actually would like to raise the
facts from the canal and river trust um
i've got a letter here dated
the 1st of march
2022
and in it they say we we reviewed the
amendment information are available and
our substantive response
uh
that is that we continue to advise the
planning permission should not be
granted
we note that it is indicated that the
application is anticipated to be
reported to the council's planning
committee for determination probably in
march
we confirm that our objection to this
application still stands and asks that
our concerns are reported to the
committee in full and i hope that will
actually form part of the discussions
that you will have on this uh on this
application
i also understand that the government
has recently introduced new guidance on
permitted developments it's quite new
and i'm not entirely sure how that might
impact on this application that you have
before you
and what it's um
what its implications are for for
permissions to be given
and i think
there are grave concerns
that the
stratford gives itself permission
for a commercial activity
on its land from which stratfor uh
cancelled benefits and there was a
strong feeling that this decision should
be made by an independent person
whatever that decision is
these concerns have been going on for so
many years
and i think this is an opportunity and a
time for an independent person to take a
view
that would be accepted as being open
clear and transparent
that everybody could accept
i'm not sure any decision this evening
would actually
resolve the issues that a number of
people
do have in the town
thank you
coach foreign thank you very much
members do you have any questions for
our member cancer dixon first please
thank you chairman councillor frankly um
taking the uh view that this council
should use an independent body to assess
it
because it's council owned or we have an
interest in it etc would you regard that
as an argument for every piece of assets
belonging to the council
please
now so fragile would you make any
distinction between this piece of land
and any other last asset
i don't believe that i would i think
there is a transparency issue here on
decisions made which actually benefit to
the body that is making that decision
any other questions members
no in that case country fragility takes
you time and contribution
if you give the desk a quick wipe that'd
be great thank you very much
okay members will open up for off uh
points clarification to our offices does
anyone have a question they want to put
to our offices
council dixon
castle fragile made reference there to
the existing markets as not having uh
sanctions and permissions
um looking through the planning history
i can see
that in 2014 change of use of land to
hold markets up to 43 days per annum was
granted
is there a difference in the piece of
land that we're talking about
was that permission in 2014
a temporary permission though it doesn't
say so on here or
was it limited to a number of years for
instance that we now have this
application before us for 43 days a year
uh thank you councillor i can feel that
question um i've got a visual um of that
planning permission to show where we are
um can you see that on my screen
at all so this is a sliver of land here
this is the 2014 permission in question
um it's immediately adjoining our
application site this evening
um i'll try and address all your
questions as best i can it was a
permanent planning permission
granted um it also allowed markets for
up to 43 days a year
and it was granted i believe in your in
2015 in your in your report pack but um
it's the landing question here is
immediately next to this application
site
council curtis
thank you um
just looking at looking at the report on
page six
um you say that uh you find there to be
substantive public benefit in the
provision of these markets i just wonder
if you could give um an idea of what
evidence you had to support that
statement
thank you
councillor um substantive public
benefits
i i've drawn upon um
some comments i've been received that
have been summarized in your third party
consultees and neighbor comments um
there has been
of course we have heard from speakers
this evening objecting there are it's
it's it would be risk not to say there's
also many people writing to support as
well um people have written in to
express their support for this
application um
quoting matters of uh
the local economy local business local
commerce and whatnot we've heard from
councillor jennings as well separately
um in terms of the public benefits that
i've quoted in the paragraph in question
um i was speaking to that um in terms of
the uh wider community benefits that
could be accrued by this development
yes there's there isn't actually any
evidence in this report though
performance is there not to speaking to
that note specifically no
thank you
seraphin
sure
um
these letters of objection and letters
of uh support
do we know how many businesses have
objected to this
um i couldn't speculate council i'm
afraid um
they they are publicly viewable for
everybody to to to conduct a poll uh if
you wish um but there i've i've
summarized those letters as best i can
uh without distinguishing between
businesses and members of the public
individuals etc
got some information there's 65
businesses of objection
we don't know what you're looking at at
the moment
i'm concerned that it's only come to you
so this is the petition and market
statement from the thousand businesses
which i believe happens
can you confirm that you've had that i'm
sure
um is this the email correspondence that
was sent on monday by any chance
just unclear this came as part of the
pack of documents that we got um earlier
in the week
okay
yeah i'm afraid i couldn't incorporate
that into the report i'm afraid that was
already written and printed in the
public domain before that email came in
i'm afraid
okay um any other questions from members
before i
get my supernovas worth um
stuart i i'm slightly confused having
seen the
drawing of the 43 that approved along
that stretch
am i right in thinking that um
that
previous permission will remain and this
will be addition too so
and and if that's right in essence could
the other portion of land be used for 43
days and then this one be used on a
separate 43 days or does it all have to
be used at the same time
um firstly your first question you are
correct that sliver of land that i
showed previously
can remain that permission has been
implemented and is materially commenced
and that can be alongside this
application so this is application is
effectively an extension of those
markets in a separate application area
um your question as to whether they
could be
separately on
two different blocks of 43 days um
i don't have that information i'm afraid
um i've treated this application
on its own merits and this this
applicant wishes to erect markets on
this application boundary for up to 43
days
a year
you said there and i might misunderstood
this that the other 43 came in as part
of this
application as part of a separate plan
permission in 2014. it's completely
separate so separate would it be
reasonable of us to potentially if we
were minded to grant put a condition on
to say that the 43 days must coincide
with 43 days of that previous permission
or is that not possible
um i'd potentially want to defer to
potentially my legal colleague in this
in that question chair if you don't mind
um
let ross think about it and then he can
respond he's ready
i think it would be useful chairman if
we could just have a look at the
documentation that came in with the
application just to check that there is
no um
direct connection between the two
because i think we've all proceeded on
the basis the expectation
that there is a deck direct connection
so can we just have a couple of minutes
to to check the paperwork to see whether
the
expectation is correct that's fine yeah
i mean my expectation is it would be
used at the same time but
there is
i want to make sure that is absolute um
because there's a danger that it could
be 86 days by splitting the two so i
just want to make that clear so you can
check that and also while um while
you're doing that um we've heard from
both our first speaker mr bond um and
from uh councillor frangley as well
um that
they would like this to have been heard
as an independent body
and there was some legal uh
frustrations i guess is the best way to
put it can you give me an idea of
whether that actually does impact what
we're doing
or whether it doesn't how that fits
i think to that i would just say that
this planning committee is obviously a
completely independent impartial
committee um it's quite normal for the
district council corporately to submit
applications to this committee
um that that the committee impartially
considers that's that's normal practice
okay thank you very much
thank you for that mr bond you've had
your opportunity to speak please please
do not shout across the room otherwise i
would have to ask you to leave
okay so we're just going to take a
briefer
we're going to take a brief adjournment
uh just for two minutes while um our
legal officers and our planning officers
just double check uh one of the
questions i've put
okay uh ladies and gents we are back um
and we are still live so um let me just
read to you the heritage statement that
was submitted and this is a brief
snippet of it um
uh which says uh that uh this isn't a
change of use application to allow for
the land known as the dust bowl or
bancroft basin to be used for the
operation of market stores for 43 days a
year and run alongside the current
market contract so the intention
is clear that it should run alongside
the 43 that 43 days have already been
approved for me i don't and i was kind
of moving into debate now i think um
for me that's not quite tight enough so
i would want to put a condition on um
should we be minded to grant um i'm
seeing some nodding heads so i think
that's probably going to happen if we
move that in that direction
otherwise we are now open to debate who
would else who else would like to say
something in debate
i will pick on people
counselor curtis good man i'll kick off
then thank you
and i think well
one general point i'd like to make is i
i am
uneasy
at the apparent
lack of public confidence
in any decision we may make this evening
i feel quite agnostic about the
the application before us i'd like to
see more evidence to support it
um i'll come on to that but i i do think
whatever decision we make it is really
extremely important that we carry the
public with us
um
one specific thing i would like to pick
up is
policy cs13 areas of restraint
which this is an area of restraint land
designated as an area of restraint makes
an important contribution
um it will need to be demonstrated that
no suitable alternative site outside the
area of restraint is available for the
proposed development i think counselor
fragility in her presentation
mentioned that we do need to try and
revitalize more
other areas of the town but the bancroft
is very well
supported if you like and i think the
we have a market area we have the market
square the roth street area and why
cannot that be used instead
thank you
hey cancer curtis councillor dixon
thank you chairman
certainly the argument here is
essentially i think one of our economics
to a certain extent but essentially
my experience of those markets when i've
visited and certainly i've attended
the young traders
finals on cop two occasions
uh as uh representing the council as in
those instances as the vice chairman and
those have been extremely popular and
have
obtained national significance in fact
the the first time i attended it was
actually on the on the bbc one night
show et cetera so essentially um i see
the markets as being productive i hear
what council curtis says about wanting
to know that it's got local support well
there's 52 letters of objection
28 of support
the vast majority
are not making any comment at all
and how you can possibly
ask for an assessment to be made as to
whether or not it has local support or
not i just don't see if you could
actually measure it unless you want to
have a referendum and that would be
totally inappropriate for a planning
application
so i hear that argument but indeed i
see this market as being productive for
the town
good economics for the town and i will
actually propose
and the support the officer's
recommendation and a proposed grant
thank you very much councillor dixon
council curtis you get sent by the
cherry thank you very much
the petition
against
this has been signed
by 65 local
business
across the town
across the piece of size ranging from
boots as i mentioned previously to much
to timson's you know so
i'm
i'm not convinced despite the report
that they're is really substantive
public benefit to the town to
locals
to businesses i wonder if there's also
been consultation
with the
care home
along along the market where about the
impact upon that as
i don't feel
this um report demonstrates that there
really is significant public benefit and
as i say referring back to what the
previous policy i mentioned
if we want to have this market why don't
we have it in an area of the town
where which needs possible greater
economic development
thank you council curtis i'll chuck my
thoughts in now if i may um
on your last point about another over
town um
unfortunately we're not here debating
another area of town we're debating this
so we have to consider the item that is
in front of us now if an application
came in another piece of land in the
town we would consider that as well but
this is what we're considering
um
for me provided that we are
able to have a robust condition to make
sure that this piece of land is used
alongside the current 43 um
simply
is looking to expand the market um
the market um which provides great
economic benefit to
small businesses that operate within
that market sphere it's an award winning
market um
within the report and counter to what
you were saying just now about um
sufficient evidence to support it i
don't see any sufficient evidence to not
support it um and really uh one needs to
see that as well in order to go against
officers recommendation to grant i can't
see any material planning grounds to go
against the officer's recommendation
so
i'm going to second cancer dixon's
proposal but i'm going to ask that we do
confirm that that condition is in
and i'm quite happy to delegate the
wording of two officers um but for the
43 days to be tied in with the existing
43 that have been approved so they can
only operate on the same days
i'm seeing some nods from them so that
we have a proposal we have a second
there would anyone else like to comment
at this point
otherwise we'll move for a vote
no okay in that case let's if we could
please have a show of hands for those in
favor of granting in line with officers
recommendation and the additional
condition please
three and those against
and abstentions
two therefore uh committee resolves to
grant application twenty one zero zero
five five seven ful uh bancroft gardens
for
the reasons given
okay thank you very much council
jennings if you want to make your way
back to your seat now members i
apologize i forgot to do a little re-jig
of the uh running order i meant to do
this at the start so i apologize um item
20 so the last item item eight i think
it is on our agenda uh 2102 507 ful i'm
going to bring that forward to be heard
now uh the reason for that is um in line
with our constitution we have no
registered speakers
and therefore we're able to delegate to
officers so i propose we delegate to
officers global secondary council dixon
grab show of hands for those in favor of
delegation please
that is unanimous so committee resolved
to delegate um application 2102 507 ful
to our officers
okay
right our next application then is um
application twenty zero zero one three
one ful snitfield sports club um in
smidfield uh our presenting officer is
charlotte dixon who's joining us online
i'm also going to have to vacate the
chair and allow council fleming to come
and sit here so
i'm going to hand over the reins to him
right right and then we need to make
sure that we've got communication with
charlotte
do we have communication with charlotte
i can hear you can you hear me okay so
it looks like charlotte can hear us but
we can't hear us so that's where we have
to press that button that's that top
left-hand button f1
i think when you press f1 you have to
switch your microphone yeah okay
can you hear me now
i'm just going to uh share my screen
so hopefully you should be able to see
that if anyone can let me know
can you make it full screen please
bear with me
we're seeing nothing charlotte i see
your face
is that full screen now
yes bingo
lovely thank you very much
right then so the site is indicated on
the map by the black circle
the application site is located at the
northern edge of snitfield at a higher
ground level than the village itself
so this slide shows the application site
edged in red the site is part of
sports club and currently benefits from
a single story sports club building on
the northern part of the site and
indicated by the yellow dot
car parking is available to the side and
front of the building
and outside of the red line there's
tennis courts here and then a bowling
green to the south
with open fields beyond to the east
the green dot to the frontage of the
site indicates the protected oak tree
so this is a full application for the
demolition of the sports club building
an erection of a replacement sports club
building and nine dwellings
the dwellings along the frontage of the
site would be set back approximately
four metres from the edge of the road
and there would be five dwellings
fronting the access drive into the site
with car parking in front of this
the new sports club building an
associated park parking would be on this
side of the site
so these images show the proposed
elevations of some of the dwellings
the front elevation is the larger image
on the left hand side of the screen
these are actually the elevations for
plots three and four three and four
which would front on to wolverton road
these dwellings are 9.6 metres in height
and would feature porches and normal
windows
this image shows the proposed elevations
of plots 7 8 and 9 which would face onto
the access road and would be the closest
plots to the tennis courts
these plots would also measure 9.6
meters in height
so this slide then shows the proposed
elevation of the replacement sports club
building which as it would be viewed
from the tennis courts
and moving on to the photos this photo
shows the site on the left hand side as
you enter the village from the north
along the wolverton road the site is
where the low fencing is visible here
with the access just beyond that
the protected oak tree is visible on the
left hand side of the screen
so this photo shows the front of the
site as viewed directly from wolverton
road the existing access is just off
screen to the right hand side and the
single story 3.6 metre high sports club
building can be seen
with the oak tree on the left hand side
of the photo
you can just see the tennis courts in
the flood lighting beyond um the
building and the bowling green on the
right hand side of the photo
so this photo is taken from the
wolverton road facing north the site is
on the right hand side
again with the oak tree visible here
and the access where the car is just
coming out of the sports club
so these plots on hale's coast are
approximately 10 meters back from the
the highway itself
so this photo is taken and panning
around showing the dwellings on hails
close
and then this photo is taken from within
the site uh from the approximate
position of the front of the five plots
facing the access road
again you can see the tennis courts on
the left-hand side with the bowling
green on the right the sports club
building would be located approximately
here beyond the tennis courts
right this photo shows the location of
the sports club building facing east
towards the existing boundary vegetation
so just to clarify there is an update
within the update sheet relating to
recent submissions and also to note that
a member site visit was carried out
early on today
so just to summarize officer
recommendation is to refuse the
application for planning permission for
the reasons and notes which can be found
on page 29 of the agenda
thank you chair
thank you charlotte thank you very much
for that
right
move on to our speakers
and
our speaker is
we have no parish council we have no
objectives
uh sam stoke from avon homes and phil
powell the architect if you'd like to
make your way forward
and uh are you both speaking or are you
i just just want to speak okay that's
just and are you answering questions if
they get asked at all
okay fine
radio
you've got three minutes
and uh
we'll give you a 30-second warning when
uh
when we get to it okay
uh good evening chair and councillors
myself and some stokes of ivan holmes
the applicant are here to address you
and answer any questions
you may have
you'll recall this application
came before you in 2021 where members
decided to defer the application
to allow the applicant to address
matters that remained outstanding
regarding highways and drainage those
matters have been resolved and there are
now no statutory objections
the proposed development comprises nine
dwellings and a clubhouse for
snitterfield sports club it fully
accords with the requirements of
snitterfield neighborhood neighborhood
plant policy ssa1
as has been previously been discussed
the um the receipts of the
nine dwellings will allow the
replacement sport club to be provided a
lower number of dwellings will not allow
the same the two elements are intrinsic
intrinsically linked and without the
residential development on the existing
clubhouse site the new clubhouse
facility will not be delivered
jeopardizing the long-term future of the
club
it is noted
the officers
raise no objection to the proposed
development in principle and the sports
club is considered acceptable however
objections have been raised by officers
to the proposed design of the
residential dwellings on matters and
also matters relating to the loss of a
young oak tree on the site
the applicant disagrees with your
officers for the following reasons
in considering the village as a whole
there are examples of use of features of
dormer windows and also buildings of
heights comparable to that proposed such
as those found at jago green hurdlers
lane snitterfield lane and shores close
the height mass and architectural
detailing of the proposed dwellings make
specific reference to buildings within
the village
in particular the picture the roofs the
detailing arches over windows
fenestration design generally are
influenced by existing styled buildings
rather than the modern buildings on the
opposite side of the the road
these can all be found within walking
distance of the site
we feel that the mention of the ridge
heights been lower towards the energy of
the villages
subjective and unsubstantiated
the proposed design of the dwellings
fronting wolverton road accord with the
policy ssa one of the neighborhood plan
which requires development to provide a
linear uh layout of homes along the road
frontage
i have prepared a sketch uh in response
to the official comments
um where the
the the plots could be recited slightly
this has been submitted to and could be
uh conditioned uh if the officers feel
that they wish to support that
turning to the tree quickly it is
proposed to remove a young oak tree
to accommodate the proposed development
and the benefits it will deliver to the
community
community
the tree's relative landscape value can
be mitigated through additional planting
within the site and the sport club have
reached agreement with the middle field
tree action group to undertake more
planting across the wider site
thank you
and does anybody have any questions for
mr stokes okay matt
yep how many trees do you intend to
plant ah good question substantial
amount i think yeah there was a uh
landscape
plan submitted um but where we've been
in regulators
all i can say is it's a substantial
amount of trees and the and the and the
snitterfield uh action groups reaction
group are
fully supportive and policy that they've
actually made the proposals which the
club will take on board
thanks to curtis yeah
thank you um
you said that the
the cost that you need to be able to
develop
all those houses to be able to pay for
the development of the sports club can
you say what the cost then of the sports
club is and what the sort of net profit
would be in your properties
well the the the affordable there's been
a affordable housing uh viability report
submitted
on behalf of council which obviously is
throwing back the
seventy thousand pound figure um so i
think that demonstrates that we've
obviously shared all of our costs but um
two lambda smith hampton who are the
councils appointed professional
consultants they've had foresight of our
appraisal so i think that's probably
best kept private confidential and
office not for this room
it doesn't but i don't think i'm going
to get the answer
i i just think if you if you
say
that you need to
have
have the properties to be able to pay
for the sports club i think it's
reasonable it's a reasonable question
it's 13 is the return on the development
30 13 13 13
yeah and that's in the financial
viability that's
public thank you for that i guess that's
really cool
any other questions yes counselor dixon
thank you chairman um
the oak tree if it wasn't there would
you be putting those houses where they
are currently being proposed or moved
them further back from the road
not not further back from the road but
we'd certainly space them more than
than
they're currently shown
this layout was amended actually when
the the tpo was placed on the tree so
the houses became closer together we've
actually redesigned them to make them
narrower and actually bring them closer
together but if the tree were removed
then the sketch layout that you you've
recently received would be implemented
that has i should hasten to add that the
houses won't become larger again we'll
actually use the narrower footprint to
give greater space and separation
between each of the dwellings
thank you again so last time we were
here we
thought about having a site visit we've
now had a site psychedelic
any other questions for the gentleman
peter yes
yes as a developer
could you not put a tree root barrier in
to protect that oak tree yeah i mean i
think there was a difference in opinion
between the council's agriculturalists
and and our instructed agriculturalist
our agriculture has said that the tree
could remain um whereas the council said
that it should
it
it should it should go i can't quite
tell you um yeah the councils are
culturally surprised that where the
buildings are currently cited that the
tree would um
would fail to survive so i think there's
a difference in opinion wasn't it there
was a difference in opinion yeah
also are you planting oak trees
we'd leave that to this the snitfield
we've got no objection to the vein oak
trees included in the planted schedule
we we know the the smithfield action
group have prepared main proposals have
you got any idea of the cost of a root
protection
barrier
the root protection barrier um
would it
sorry if we were to put the root
protection barrier into the scheme it
would mean that the setting out of the
current proposal would would remain as
it's
currently proposed it can be delivered
yeah
because it's a young oak tree it doesn't
fully spread yet
no it hasn't and that's i think that's
part of the debate is about the the
space that it's got to to grow okay
thank you peter you ever
answer your question
thank you very much thank you
just give the table to wipe over before
you leave
next week is our award member
cancer peter richards
thank you
you have five minutes sir
thank you council fleming members um i'd
like to start by thanking you all for
for those of you that managed to make it
to the uh site visit this afternoon
despite the thumping rain um thank you
very much i think it's vitally important
that uh that you were able to see that
and understand uh what is being proposed
and in particular how it fits in with
the village and with the street scene
you've seen for yourself that the club
is in critical need of renovation uh
frankly it needs knocking down and
rebuilding
it is unsafe
that's been known for some time in
2014-15 when the village started on its
neighbor development plan there was a
huge amount of discussion about this
site then ultimately the ndp committee
concluded that this site should be
developed for nine homes and a new
sports club under policy ssa one and as
you've heard as you've heard the the ndp
itself was supported by 94 percent of
residents at the at the referendum stage
that for me shows overwhelming local
support having spoken to a number of the
ndp committee members throughout this
application i'm also told that the
current proposal is more or less exactly
how it was envisaged when it was being
put through the neighborhood development
plan
regrettably though we are now in front
of you with a recommendation for refusal
it is pleasing to note that the previous
five reasons for refusal that the
applicants have been able to provide the
necessary information to overcome at
least two of those so we're now left
with just three reasons to consider
today so if i may take those in reverse
order so looking at reason number three
first of all this relates to the offsite
affordable housing contributions the
case office suggests that the
contribution has not yet been secured
however on page 14 of your report it
clearly states that the applicants have
agreed to a 70 000 contribution towards
offsite affordable housing that figure
has been arrived through an independent
viability assessment and now simply
needs to be secured to an s106 that can
be included as a condition as a subject
to s106 condition and so that reason
falls away
looking now at uh reason for refusal
number two which relates to the removal
of the oak tree uh you'll recall a
lengthy and detailed debate at this
committee for a tpo to be placed on that
tree uh quite some time after this
application was deferred last year and
to my
knowledge the only time a tpo has ever
come before this committee
it was made clear then by our own
officers that tpo in itself would not
prevent development going ahead and
could be removed should suitable
mitigation be presented
in this instance the development
proposed to replace the single tree with
a planting scheme of over 200 new trees
and shrubs across the site
you will also i also happen to know that
at the weekend a mature oak tree was uh
was planted in the playing fields
directly opposite um as a almost as an
offset for for the loss of this tree
forgive me i've lost my
uh my point um you'll also recall the
passionate representations from the
parish council myself and residents
against the tpo as the tree was not
considered to be mater of material
importance to the village and the
residents i'm a firm believer in
localism and with a level of support
against that tpo and for this
application alongside the mitigation of
over 200 additional trees being planted
i find this a very compelling reason to
allow the removal of tree t2 and so this
reason once again falls away
so that leaves us with the just the
first reason for refusal which relates
to design scale layout and sighting
that is very much subjective and each of
us have a differing view on such matters
in these circumstances i believe it is
right for us to give significant weight
to the opinions of the local residents
that this development directly impacts
we know that 94 of the village supported
this development through the ndp process
and during the application there have
been more than 70 letters of support
with just 11 objections for me that
gives us a good steer as to how
residents see this development fitting
in with the village
and satisfies me that the development
would be appropriate in design scale and
layout and sighting
um however i do have a good
understanding of the village and the
location of the sports club in relation
to the other areas of the village those
of you that joined us on the site visit
will have seen for yourselves the
properties along wolverton road and in
dutton's close and hell's close which is
directly opposite are tightly packed and
do closely above the road
to my mind this development does fit in
with and relates to the character of the
surrounding area and it does preserve
the special landscape area particularly
when compared to the surrounding forms
of development indeed the case officer
states on page 20 of your report that
from the evidence submitted i consider
that this is the only available site for
the sports club and considering the
support within the village an ongoing
provision of this important community
asset i conclude that the visual impact
and impact on the openness of the
greenbelt would in this case be
outweighed by the community benefits
identified from the redevelopment
so
with an s 106 agreement to secure funds
for affordable offsite uh offsite
affordable housing the mitigation for
the 30 seconds of the oak tree by
replacing it with 200 new trees
the two reasons for refusal those two
reasons fuse will have fallen away that
leaves you to be satisfied that the
design scale and layout of the
development is appropriate for this
location in my opinion the proposal does
fit in the local character of the
village and is overwhelmingly supported
by residents the parish council the
neighborhood development plan myself and
we have no objections from statutory
consultees
add to that the community benefits
identified for the developments that
outweigh the harm identified i implore
you to grant this application the
reasons given to enable sports club to
continue to fund draw successfully thank
you
and we have any questions for the world
member
council curtis
thanks
thank you councillor richards um
you mentioned the 200 trees i mean
no one wants to see semi-mature trees um
fell
obviously but and i just want to you
mentioned the 200 trees which is
fantastic do you know would they just be
sort of whips or would some of them be
more substantial saying mature do you
have any idea what you could tell them
um sadly i don't have the benefit of the
uh the plan in front of me i believe our
officers may have had it already um but
certainly you can condition if you want
to have some semi-mature um i'm sure
it's in within your gift to be able to
condition that should be which yeah
thank you i think that might it's worth
bearing in mind that a semi-mature tree
as i say was planted directly opposite
the site uh in you know replacement for
the t2 thank you
any other question councillor dixon
council richards um you mentioned of
course the 70 000 pounds uh offer a
secretary which reminded me it may be a
question that i should have asked the uh
agents as such um because obviously
there is also within our papers a a sill
payment uh calculated there at forty
thousand seven hundred and five uh so
may i assume
if you know uh is it both seventy
thousand plus the forty thousand could
one be in jeopardized by the other
my understanding is that it would be
both um but i would suggest you see
clarifications from your offices
any other questions for the ward member
no okay you can step down counselor
thank you very much
right and now that we've heard all the
speakers on this one
um clarification for the officers if you
have a question for the officer bear
with me one second while i press all
these buttons
this would be interesting
thank you chairman i think the officers
probably know the question uh is it 70
000 plus the sale payment please
thank you counselor yes um um the
payment required would be that the sale
money as well as the the 70 000 pounds
for the affordable housing contribution
if members were minded to to grant the
permission
through you chairman
through you chairman uh
is that what the is that the
understanding of the applicants or that
simply what we're saying is what will be
required
i would need to have a check through the
financial viability information
submitted but they are aware that the
sale money has been requested and it has
been um discussed with the the agents
beforehand and it's been in the public
domain for certainly well over a year um
that the sale money would be required in
addition to any affordable housing
contribution
thank you
if we
are minded to
grant
permission
are we also able at this meeting
to remove
the tpo
we obviously put the tpo on in order to
protect the situation
but my
viewing of that history today
when i think of tpos i think of them as
being on significant and mature trees
this oak tree has the potential to
become a mature and significant oak tree
but currently it is not so i'm just
wondering if we
as a committee
without the application before us can
actually remove a tpo
i'll answer a little bit of that myself
actually because um we uh
i sat on the chair i chaired the
committee that where we did that and i
seem to remember from the uh the
description of the tree it was a prime
grade one tree
um of approximately 50 years old and at
the time it
it was you know i mean in perfect
condition
so
i'm not when does it become a tree of
sort of national importance or a local
importance so i might have to ask
officers for that perhaps i could turn
it
yeah thank you chair um
the presentation from the applicants was
an absolute classic example of the sort
of answers we've had from them over the
last two years
um they seem to be unsure whether
they're proposing to remove the tree or
not as part of this application
we are proceeding this application is
this report is expecting the tree to be
removed
it's expecting the tree to be removed
for a number of reasons
mainly because
whether or not a root barrier can be
constructed around the tree to allow it
to continue to grow
if it does grow it's in such a
relationship with the proposed houses
that the residents will feel threatened
by it they'll be concerned about
dropping branches
so it has no long-term future life so
we're working on the basis that it will
be failed so
any recommendation any decision to grant
permission will be at the same time
expecting this tp this this tree to be
failed yes we are completely content
with that
i do remember from that previous
meeting where we
impacted the tpo
uh they said at any time if this plan of
mission was granted it would override
that tpo anyway yes
charlotte did you want to come in on
that at all
i'm sorry i think i missed part of what
um what was discussed then is it still
in relation to the tree
i'll end up talking to myself again um
yeah just really that uh the uh the pla
planning permission would override the
tpo anyway
yes that's right so any planning
permission for the works um that members
are assessing tonight would um result in
the removal of the tree and it would
override the tpo on the oak tree yes
any other questions for the officer
right we should move forward into
our debating then
okay jennings
and we've spoken about uh
about the developer and obviously them
needing to make a profit 13 profits
really low on this
um
it's
no developer is ever going to do
anything as a that's a kind gesture
there's always got to be that balancing
act to level it up
um
the
the sports community sports center is in
a terrible state and
you know
it
it needs to be replaced which is
obviously why everyone in
in the villages has agreed you know they
have weighed up they've weighed it up
and uh that's why
94
are in favor of it i mean it's sort of
it's really rare to get that level of
support everyone seems to be in favor
after the visit today uh
i was i was somewhat surprised by the
size of the oak tree
um
what i was expecting something a lot
bigger um
and i think the fact that they are going
to
grow 200 other trees or plant to enter
the trees um
certainly certainly makes up for it
i went i drove round and i looked at all
the other houses there and they are
tightly compact
i don't see any particular difference
in in with these houses they might be
slightly slightly taller
but
you know you've got to get the bedrooms
in somewhere it's as simple as that
um
with with regards to
the uh
the final issue
the s-106 condition
uh
and the 70 000 it seems to
seems to tick all the boxes
um
i'm leaning very much in favor of
at this stage of uh going against the
officer's recommendation
chairman i'm sorry to interrupt but i
wonder if i can just help members a
little bit here
councillor um
richards and councillor jennings you
you're both absolutely right that
conditions two and three will fall away
if sorry reasons two and three will fall
away if you find reason one to be flawed
and obviously to assess reason one you
need to be going back to the planning
policy not to the applicant's profits
if you think that reason one is is
incorrect and the applicants are
complying with the development plan then
you will be right to go ahead and grant
permission and not worry at all about
reasons two and three i hope that helped
it does
anybody else like to join in the debate
peter come on yeah thank you
we don't have any uh objections to the
development of the sports club or
they've been houses there
i think
there is probably a slight over
development of the houses uh the one
nearest the uh
tennis ground seems to be very close
um i would like to see and
a protection on this tree with the root
barrier there wouldn't be that expensive
all trees uh especially an a103
shouldn't be discarded
it's home to a lot of living things
and if you want to ask the residents who
live there please go and ask them birds
insects
but it's
it is a mature oak oaks take a long time
to build to build up their
density
um
and it would be a shame that that oak
tree comes down
i have no objections about the
development i just think that that
too many it's a bit over developed on
the side and i think probably isos would
be the maximum
thank you
okay
thank you chairman
in my mind there were two issues
regarding this proposed development
that's the ridge height of the proposed
houses
and the proximity of
plots one two three and falls to the
road
having
attended the site visit today
my concerns
regarding those are not alleviated
but
the whole of the parish the residents
the locals community are the people who
ultimately i feel
have to live
with what they are supporting
because they are supporting it
i too am supporting it
but the simple reason that
whilst i have the concerns and i can
understand the officers concerns it is
a matter of degree and on reflection
i will go against the officer's
recommendation and i would be supporting
a grant of this application
is that a proposal cancer dixon
i would happily propose it but okay
essentially the reasons and the rest of
it is a disagreement with condition one
i think it is not uh unreasonable
do we have anybody
thank you yes just agreeing with
councillor dixon i've been
concerned that on a number of occasions
the planning committee does
appear to
give
inadequate weight
shall i say
to uh the views of
local residents of parish councils
and so on and i think we in this
instance um i mean i do have some
reservations but looking at the
overwhelming support from the parish
council and residents in snitter field i
think we really should give
that due consideration by making our
decision on this
is that a second it's a cancer dixon
yes i believe it is okay
what we have to be mindful for and do we
have sufficient
reasons to go against the officer's
recommendations and if we do what would
they be
okay
we're we're happy with the design scale
and layout of the proposal
um
sorry thank you for that members um yeah
i'm i'm comfortable that you are coming
to a different conclusion to us over
design scale and layout uh and therefore
that you feel the the scope of the
development is acceptable in the form
shown on the submitted plans
where i'm going to need some help from
members is on two other items the first
is obviously we're going to need a
section 106 obligation for the seventy
thousand pound contribution for
affordable housing
but the second is if you turn to the uh
policy that's enabling this development
in the first place ssa one snitterfield
sports club in the neighborhood
development plan
it says development will only be
supported
if there is an adequate mechanism in
place to secure appropriate replacement
sports facilities in a suitable location
now we can't take this on a promise
yes i promise that if you let me build
nine houses i'll build a sports club
we have to have some
formal mechanism to deliver that and i'm
asking members what mechanism they would
like us to use for that how we are going
to ensure that it's delivered
um i don't know whether ross can offer
some assistance but i think that's what
we need to hear yeah i think you could
that could be included in the section
106 agreement
yeah just it's just to guarantee that
the delivery of the
sports club so we'd need to give some
thought to how that's done but in
principle it could be done through a 106
agreement
just just for clarity chairman um sorry
ross and i are playing ping pong here
either side of you i do apologize
um
what what we would normally do with
things like uh i don't know public open
space is we would ask for the public
open space to be delivered after
percent fifty percent seventy percent of
the houses are built uh it would be
useful if we could have some guidance
from members how they see the sequence
going because
presumably this development will have to
be largely or completely sold
before the the the club can be developed
what what sort of periods are you
comfortable with members are you
comfortable with the club coming forward
only after the houses have been built
i i i just just looking for guidance
i really struggle on that because i'm no
expert in it and like if i was to turn
around and
suggest something which is totally
unreasonable or unfeasible it's
it's not going to help any it's not
going to help anything
um
i would we would need
guidance and i'm
surely that would be something in the
106 because i think the detail could be
delegated to officers i mean you're
concerned to secure the delivery of the
sports facilities and
we your officers could work out the
details of how that's
done yeah go on
thank you very much chairman remembers i
i hopefully this helps but just so
you're clear the uh the agreement and
the contract between uh even homes and
the sports club is that they will
deliver the sports club before they
build the houses so if you wanted to
include that as either as conditional
s106 i think that ties up what you're
debating now
that's really helpful thank you
um
charlotte charlotte
sorry um we've just been talking about
the um
about the s106 and and how we build the
sports club and how we build the houses
and we've just been told that they
intend to build the sports club before
the houses are worked on um have you got
any issues with that at all
um
as long as we can
include in the section 106 that the
sports club
is provided and that satisfactory
mechanism for that then that would uh
um comply with ssa1 in the ndp
thank you for that thank you
okay charlotte i think we're uh i think
we're we know where we're going with
this now so
we'll we'll move forward with a vote in
a moment thank you
okay let's have the microphones on
members it does help
just a set
is everything
is everybody happy to leave the officer
to set the conditions yes chairman
thank you
thank you chairman we'll do it in
agreement with you we'll show you what
we're doing before we issue a chairman
okay thank you very much
unanimous
thank you everybody thank you for that
the uh
the decision is to grant the application
against the officer's recommendation
until the conditions will be set by
planning and that they'll keep us in
touch with what they're going to do
okay members i am back in the seats now
um and we are all ready to go so our
next item now we're going to take the
next two items as one presentation but
we will hear the speakers and have a
deliberation of debate independently so
um we're gonna hear a presentation for
application uh sixteen zero two one four
seven out and twenty zero one three six
eight f u l both at dallas person polo
club our presenting officer is louise
coleman louise whenever you're ready
over to you
thank you chair
can everyone see the screen
we can thank you okay thank you
members this presentation covers items
five and six on your agenda they are
both at dallas burst and polo grounds
the first is an outline application for
the erection of a 130 bed hotel with
access under consideration and the
second is a full application for the use
of land for up to 100 pitches for
touring caravans and camper vans
this site is identified by the black dot
on the map
the next plan shows the overall site of
dallas burst and edged in blue with long
itchington and afton woods which is a
triple s i an ancient woodland to the
west and thorpe rough ancient woodland
to the north
it also shows the proposed line of hs2
in pink part of that will form a tunnel
underneath the site
stonythorpe hall identified in red
lights of the east and two public
footpaths identified by the green hatch
line run through the site
this slide shows the area of land taken
for construction works by hs2 to create
the tunnel
clearly it's going to affect the access
to the site during the construction
phase identified in yellow
this slide shows the position of the two
applications the 100 pitches on the
western end and the 130 bed hotel
position centrally adjacent to the
existing ixl conference center 43-bed
hotel and public house known as
millstone hair
these applications were referred to
committee in december 2020 and deferred
to resolve highway objections and also
for the submission of an updated master
plan
this is the master plan showing the
development which has permission and is
either completed or under construction
this is a plan showing a master plan for
the
for the foreseeable future showing the
location of the proposed hotel
identified by number 11
and the hundred pictures identified by
number eight
and also the position of the 140 bed
hotel which has lapsed
and also the arena and stables which is
pending consideration
this is the indicative outline of the
hotel it measures approximately 104
meters in length and varies in width
from 16 to 35 meters
this is a view of the
proposed location of their hotel from
the public path that crosses the eastern
part of the site
most
milestone hair
identified here has a varied ridge
height of seven meters up to
approximately 10 meters in height and
the hotel would be four-story and up to
17 meters in height
this is a view from the public footpath
sm
180 and also the residential development
known as solas gardens located here
and here
with the
hotel
being located in this vicinity here
this is the location for the hundred
pictures
for the touring caravans and campervan
application
the site is 5.3 hectares and each square
apologies and each square
identified on the plan here um
is a pitch the applicant has confirmed
that the route of hs2 does not run
underground where the camping facility
is proposed so there's
therefore no loss of capacity for
camping in relation to the application
site
this is a view looking west and then
below looking south
the boundary hedgerows are proposed to
be retained
there is one update to report in
connection with the hotel application
additional comments have been received
from councillor adams raising objection
and there are a number of updates in
connection with a hundred pitch
application um in particular
clarification has been received from the
highway authority stating that the
square blocks shown on the proposed
layout plan are sufficient to park a car
untouring caravan or campervan and in
light of this the second reason for
refusal is recommended to be omitted
also comments have been received from
councillor adam um raising objection to
the development
the recommendation is for with respect
to the hotel application is to refuse
the applications for the
application for the two reasons listed
in the committee report
and for the um 100 pitch application
is to refuse the first
to refuse the application for the first
reason listed in the committee report
and to omit the second reason
thank you chair
louise thank you very much indeed okay
members uh we will call for our first
speaker on this item who is major
richard carney
good evening and welcome i think you've
got an idea of how things are going to
proceed so you'll have three minutes
i'll give you a 30 second warning but as
soon as you're set and comfortable if
you press the button in the middle of
your microphone it'll go red and the
floor is yours
good evening um i'm the director of
operations for dallas burst and polar
grains i'm the chairman of shakespeare's
england as members will know that
the underlying strategy for
shakespeare's england is to maximize
visitors numbers to south warwickshire
and also increase overnight stays
a current day visitor to the region
spends in excess of 30 pounds whereas an
overnight stay is well in excess of 300
pounds close to 400 pounds
the original stone you thought manor
plan considered by this authority in
2009 identified 140 bed hotel in 2013 we
secured outline planning
planning permission for this hotel but
could not implement the permission
because of the size of the land take by
hs2
hence the repositioning of the hotel of
a similar size as is now proposed
this hotel is needed to support the
large events held at the iselle event
centre which is now a well established
events venue in the county
most weekends a large wedding event is
held with guests ranging between 400 and
600
and we have insufficient overnight
accommodation at present to meet the
demand
during the week the business opportunity
to host large scale corporate events is
frustrated by the lack of overnight
accommodation
the organizers of business tourism
events seek to accommodate the majority
of delegates on site and are
increasingly reluctant to manage the
logistics of transferring delegates to
off-site hotel accommodation and
returning delegates the next day
this results in unnecessary traffic
movement to and from the site to hotels
which are some distance from stonythorpe
and many will be located in the nec and
birmingham area
the proposed hotel will involve a
further investment of some six million
pounds uh it will provide employment for
47 people
the hotel is needed
to complement the substantial investment
that has already been undertaken in the
provision of sporting and events venues
at the polar grains some hundred million
pounds
the dallas burst and polar grains make a
significant contribution to the local
economy the hotel is
is certainly uh directly associated with
an existing major events venue and is
ancillary to it
it would be very disappointing if this
authority having granted planning
permission for the size of the hotel in
2013 and the investment frustrated by
hs2
now denies consent for its relocation
on land unaffected by hs2 it is not
realistic to commercially envision this
investment taking place and save them is
only the
locational
synergy between the events venues at
stoney thorpe and the proposed hotel
that make it investment viable
i hope members will support um this
further
investment
thank you very much indeed memphis do
you have any questions council jennings
how often do you put on events which uh
more than one day
do you put on two or three day events
most polar events there's a number so
most polar events are two days
so the teams turn up on a friday evening
they stay on saturday and go back late
sunday night sometimes monday morning it
depends on how far they're traveling we
also have our wedding guests which are
generally
two night events
um the corporate events midweek
are generally three
two three
day events
so yes
um obviously kobe does code things down
but last year we had
um
57 events which were in excess of two
days
all right so another question yeah it
had um
how difficult is it to book book event
sorry book rooms in local hotels wasn't
this where are the nurse households the
issue we have at the moment is that
you'll find new stratford as well if you
obviously um
using the assessment sorry is that
most uh venues
that would take these number of guests
are the holiday or they're so far away
so
the type and level of hotel has actually
become an issue so the closest hotel to
us is mallory course
um
but that is really
without price 30
of our wedding guests
and
90
of our corporate guests
okay remembers any other questions
uh i have one if i may and before i ask
you i should have said this earlier i
have actually been to the polo the
dallas person playground and i've also
been to a wedding there for full
disclosure but i am here with an open
mind so i just thought i'd better make
that point now um the
scot size scale design layout etc of the
hotel as is proposed now
does it
forgive me the microphone that i've got
has just decided to die um i'll start
that again um the
hotel as it is proposed now how does it
materially differ in terms of its size
scale layout et cetera from that that
was granted before are they identical or
are they dramatically different
they're they're quite close yeah i think
the facade i think it's got some pillars
on the front that
the original one had a golf had a
cricket pitch in the front and the
facade didn't come out it sort of sank
him more so it's minimal so the main
bulk of the hotel is more or less
identical it's just changing the facade
okay thank you um council jennings
yeah how much
yeah sorry i just it is actually smaller
in size
it's 10 bedrooms short smaller which is
actually on earlier spaces
yeah okay i'll i will get the
double
confirmed for us but thank you i
appreciate that council jennings yeah so
how much you are you investing in this
in this hotel
um the first draft is 6.75 million
so you must be pretty confident that
it's gonna you're gonna be able to fill
it
yes we've had um we've had a number of
surveys done by quite reputable
obviously companies about the the um the
business plan etc yeah we are very
confident for the sort of money we spend
on that site yes we are
okay any further questions at this point
no in that case major connie thank you
very much for your time contribution
now we do have council adam registered
to speak although as you know he has
given his apologies sadly um there is an
update on the update sheet have you had
a chance to read that
yes is that yes from everyone good um
i think we can safely assume that that
is the representations that uh council
adam would have made so we will move on
um and move to points for clarification
for our officers um i'll kick us off by
may louise so the first one is in terms
of the um differences between the
previously approved and now lapsed
permission for the hotel and this hotel
can you tell us what the major
differentiation is between them please
certainly um the previous application in
2009 um whilst of a similar uh footprint
um to what is being proposed but the um
the
the officer's report identifies
indicative
elevations bearing in mind it was an
outline as well
and
it measured from between 11 meters to
13 and a half meters to its ridge height
and there was a condition attached on
that outline permission um to ensure
that his ridge height is going to be
varied with this application we haven't
received any elevational um treatments
um we have been
we have received indicative um
layouts um but the the
the difference is that this would be
proposed to be up to 17 meters in height
and full story rather than three uh
three and a half as previously uh
presented
okay thank you very much members do you
have any other questions counselor
curtis first
thank you
and i just wonder if we could see on on
that map on that on on that uh photo
where the where the previous site of the
hotel was intended to be
certainly
able to show us that yes i can
get some feedback remember turning
microphones on and off please members
um council jennings next please
uh he has mentioned that some of it's
underground and i'm presuming by that
some of it's not
whereabouts is the the not bit
the
the route
is taken under here it goes under
underneath the site here
and if we go
back to the line
the rest of it is all underneath the
underneath the polar ground
i'm sorry i missed the the cursor was
going a bit too quickly is it basically
go under the road it does as far as i'm
aware and then comes up and then goes
above ground for the rest of the way
none of it is above ground as far as i'm
aware within within the site itself
possibly
well this is the main access uh where
are we sorry no this is the main axis
into the site um
i think you would have to seek
clarification from the um
applicant um
with exactly
the the area where it's been tunneled
is around this area confirm now do you
want to come forward measure um now it's
just a point of clarification so just
yes
the whole um
from the top the north of the picture
all under longitudinal wood all the way
down until it gets where the road the
blue uh road is you know the link at the
bottom in the safe you come all the way
down and bit further
keep coming down and it pops out there
ah it sees 30 meters on the ground all
that perfect
okay thank you very much
i can hear the question brewing in
councillor jennings mind can i answer it
chairman that you can wait surely we
should wait until he asks
the reason for the ground disturbance is
obviously to create the tunnel which
will then be covered over once the
tunnel is created
um okay members do we have any other
points clarification for our officer
in which case let's move into debate who
would like to kick us off
council jennings this is going to be me
um
obviously
there's a huge demand for hotels um
[Music]
i noticed uh
um that
to get
so i'm just really trying to just trying
to read this quickly
no i i just go into that right economic
development economic benefits
are huge um it will create
47 jobs but of course there'll be
auxiliary jobs in all the towns around
um
it will also benefit the local
businesses
you normally find the hotels
will source locally
um
there's
the hotel
it was previously granted
um it's over to me it's a similar
similar footprint
um
i guess there are there are slightly
ecological benefits to it that you're
not getting especially with all the
horse
and with all the horse shows none i'm
not a horsey person but my wife is
and uh whenever they go along to any of
these events they turn up there in old
trucks and lorries and and
trailers
and they've got to stay somewhere
if there's no hotels there there's no
hotel there they've all got to go off
site they've got to find somewhere else
they're driving around polluting
um
i guess you sort of you're guessing
where i'm going on this one but i'll
let other people put their two pennies
worth in
thank you councillor jennings councillor
dixon please
thank you chairman just looking at the
uh the officer's conclusion
um
the effect there is that uh in regards
to the above the proposed hotel is not
considered to be genuinely ancillary or
directly associated with current
business
would have a detrimental effect on the
landscape and would harm the setting of
a grade two listed stony hall and
stables with insufficient public benefit
to outweigh the harm
well i think there's a lot of public
benefit from having a decent-sized hotel
etc and the economy and the people who
will bring cash to the community
by way of overnight stays etc so i think
there is some public benefit which
indeed does outweigh any harm so
i think uh councillor jennings might be
supportive but i'm supportive of
agreement
uh again sorry to interrupt you i i do
apologize but i need to i need to
um um ross just reminded me that there's
an update that we should have had on the
update sheet and counselor dixon has
just read out the update that we should
have done which is to excise
the harm to the setting of the grade two
listed stony thought paul everything
else you said council dixon absolutely
correct and i'm not disagreeing with
anything you said um but please
disregard that section of that sentence
we intended to delete it and didn't
that was worth being interrupted for so
thank you uh council dixon have you made
a formal proposal left
i would propose that we have for granted
uh we'll need to go through a bit more
detail and reasons why we're going
against but i'm sure we can come to that
in a second does anyone else want to
have anything to say in the debate
before i check my thoughts in cancer
center seraphim please yeah i i just
have concerns it being a four story it
will stand out on the landscape quite
significantly to what originally was
three story that would be my objection
to it not objecting in principle to
ourselves
thank you very much cancer family
yeah
it being four-story that it does have a
disadvantage but i think it's less of a
disadvantage if it was three-story and a
much bigger footprint
um so from that perspective i think that
that is probably a better option to go
four-story i know that's what's
important i know we have this thing
about how we decide which way we're
going but i think that's the right way
to go and the other the the second point
is
um all the people that go and stay in
this hotel won't stay there all weekend
we might see a few in stratford and
center that spend a little bit
on the tourism so i think there's wider
spread benefits other than what will
happen on the land so
i'd i'd be inclined to
to support that we grant it
thank you very much
would counselor curtis like to complete
the set or not don't feel you have to
okay cool so i'm going to chuck i'm
going to check my thoughts in if i may
cast jans first of all um i'm going to
focus on the reasons for refusal first
of all so um reason one um essentially
about uh about the whether it's
ancillary or not in my mind this is
clearly ancillary to the wider site and
we've heard that from
the representations that have been made
um
knowing that and we'll think about that
the economic benefits that this will
bring are in my mind huge um but we also
with policy cs24 i think it is um
supports any ancillary uh development
that would support local sport and sport
and countryside etc i'm being shown it
now yes it's there um so it's been
confirmed this is exactly what this is
doing we're looking to support um a
business that a sporting venue that is
already in place
um given that we know a hotel has
already been granted on the site and
sadly lapsed um
i feel very strongly that we should be
supporting uh the principle of the hotel
now it's worth bearing in mind this is
an outline application
um so we are only looking at the
principle when it comes to the design
layout scale size etc that will come
through a full application so we do have
i believe and i'm sure ross will tell me
otherwise i do believe we have the um
facility now
if we're uncomfortable with the height
or the size to be able to set a height
or size
so that comes to uh point two for the
reasons of refusal whether the size and
height of the pros hotel would be
uncharacteristically large
four stories i think probably would be
um i would be mind to say to have either
a note or a condition to say that the
final design should be comparatively
similar to what was granted previously
in terms of its height i don't know how
people feel about that whether they feel
strongly one way or the other
yes sorry i mean sorry i'd um
i
share uh counseling
seraphim's concerns about the height and
whether it would be overbearing but
taking what you just said i find that
reassuring that this is only outlined
and that we would be able to determine
the height so were that the case i would
be in favor of supporting this
uh so council jennings did sigma earlier
come to you in a second
i've noticed that no one's actually
seconded this so i'd like to second it
okay
council dixon i was just wondering if we
understand the topography of the site
because obviously the one that has
lapsed is number 12 on the map the
proposed site is number 11 admittedly
obviously outline and i'm just wondering
if 11 is any higher or lower than 12 in
the landscape
don't know if
we know the answer to that question
let's find out louise do you know the
answer to that please
um
no i haven't got the levels um details
to hand it may be a question that you
may be able to to ask the the agent
the the the position of number 11
during my site visits obviously
is existing uh uses polo ground um it is
relatively flat um and
in comparison to the um
lxl building and milestone
milestone hair building which is just to
the north it's
it looks comparable to that to those
thank you louise um i having vis the
site before i'm pretty sure it's flat um
i'm seeing some nods from um the
applicant so
i i would work on that basis
um
okay we have a proposal that's been
seconded um i'm going to add to your
proposal your proposal was to grant
essentially because you uh you believe
that this is ancillary uh to the
existing use and supported therefore by
cs24 um
that you don't think the size and height
would result in uncharacteristically
large feature in the open countryside
i'm going to contest the second one and
ask you to include a note
that says uh that full the full
application should be no higher than the
previously approved i think i think
someone said 13 meters there was a
condition on that to vary the ridge
heights so that note to include
something about varying ridge heights as
with a per the previous application are
you happy for that to be included
i wouldn't disagree
whether any other members would disagree
i don't know but i would i would be
happy with that we'll find out if they
disagree when we go to the vote so
that's a yes from you councillor
jennings are you happy as a seconder
you put your microphone on say yes yes
marvelous okay so um are you satisfied
that we've covered all bases yes jeff
you're satisfied as well ross
i'll take that as a yeah yeah okay
perfect okay so uh proposal is to grant
um
including the note as i've just set out
uh application sixteen zero two one four
seven out could i please have a show of
hands for those in favor
that is unanimous so committee resolved
to grant application 1602 147 outline uh
for the reasons given including a note
and the conditions will come to you for
agreement yes please
marvelous okay um we now move to um
application 20 0 1 3 6 8 full for which
we've already had our presentation um so
we will move to our first speaker who is
peter frampton
mr frampton if you could make your way
forward thank you very much um i know
this isn't your first time so you know
the drill three minutes 30 second
warning when you're ready the floor is
yours
sorry mr phantom could you turn your
microphone on just dealing with the
first reason for refusal relating to the
principle of development policy cs24
members are clearly aware of the
significance of the tourism sector to
the local economy the council has
approved a local industrial and economic
strategies 2018 to 2031 which has a
section on tourism your planning
officer's report makes no reference to
this strategy
overnight visitors presently contribute
44 of total visitor expenditure
fundamentally the strategy seeks to
increase its expenditure by increasing
overnight accommodation
the dallas burst and polar grounds are i
believe the largest events and sporting
venue in the district hosting major
indoor and outdoor events throughout the
year views as you've heard the ixl
center which is one of the largest
indoor centers in the county can host up
to 800 guests in a theater style
the master plan requested by the
planning committee when these
applications were last reported was
submitted last february to your planning
february 2021 an underlying component of
that strategy of the master plan is to
provide a wide range of overnight
accommodation to give choice to visitors
in terms of the form of accommodation
and price presently no provision is
available for touring caravans and
campervans the proposals broaden the
offer of overnight accommodation as an
extension to the approved 50 static
caravans in 50 years the proposal is
directly associated with an existing
major events venue
outdoor events such as polo tournaments
and shows can attract several thousand
visitors from across the uk the
provision for caravans and campervans
will provide an opportunity for visitors
to stay on site for the duration of
these events or reducing vehicular
movements for going off-site to off-site
accommodation the primary planning use
of this site is the events venue this
proposal is genuinely ancillary there
too
the form of occupation will be
influenced by the type of event that is
held large-scale entertainment events
such as sports fixtures are likely to
attract more visitors to the caravan and
camping grounds than corporate events in
the ixl center i hope members will
welcome the proposed investment in the
tourism sector and conclude that this
proposal is compliant with policy cs24
and as10 and will make also a
significant contribution to the approved
strategy to increase overnight tourism
accommodation in the district and
enhance the local economy
thank you i was just about to give you
30 second warning well done
um members we have any questions from mr
frampton please cancel dixon first sorry
council jennings first
released a result um
in
employing more staff
the the management of the site of this
scale most certainly will in terms it'll
be a few people required to manage the
arrivals and departures of people
coming to a site of this scale yes
given the what that we've just granted
now an approval for a rather large hotel
um you're obviously confident that this
is an alternative
uh style of overnight accommodation will
be used sufficiently
yes very much so i mean
you're looking as for a broad choice um
um the
hotel will be uh
costly relative to actually pulling your
caravan or driving onto a camper van so
it broadens the choice of overnight
accommodation to suit a range of prices
and so that broadens it out to a wider
range of the community
okay thank you
members do we have any other questions
from mr frampton please
no in that case we're sorry oh no
councillor jennings has one
event
um well the the the polar grounds as you
aware there's town
fine and country there are different
events other than the polo tournaments
uh they could be cycling events uh there
could be external um festivals a whole
range of uses could be there these
grounds will also be very popular for
the commonwealth great games which is
the summer of this year you've got
the bowls event the parabolas event in
levington spa you've got the cycling
road cycling of race starting in warwick
and finishing in warwick and these will
be very well located to that so it
broadens out the tourism offer in this
district
is the dance person site offering any um
facility for the commonwealth games or
are any of the sporting events being
held there there are none of the
sporting events being held there
chairman just nobody it's the proximity
of this site
for people spectators road race cycling
is very very popular for spectators
that's being held in warwick understood
thank you uh members any other questions
in that case thank you thank you very
much
okay um so counselor adam once again has
registered to speak um but as we know
he's not here so his once again his
representations made within the update
sheet are the ones that you need to be
aware of
we will now move to point of
clarification to our offices would
anyone like to ask a question to our
officers
no
in that case let's move into debate who
would like to kick us off in the debate
council dixon
well i must admit i did wonder whether i
ought to be declaring an interest
baby boomers of which i'm one
um an awful lot of my friends have got
mobile homes mobile camper vans um the
number of those who go around the
country and enjoy themselves spending
funds and money elsewhere is
quite a i'm almost jealous of them
because
not something that
actually appeals to myself but
nevertheless it is in the family and as
i say i know plenty of friends so
certainly a situation whereby i do know
that
uh it is good to have a different price
point the hotel accommodation um might
not be overly expensive don't know
but certainly there's a distinct
distinct distinction between the prices
you would be paying if you arrive in
your own camper van on the site and pay
a fee for the lot as it were overnight
shower facilities and the like
uh as compared to staying in a hotel so
certainly it'll appeal to two different
categories of of residents and of locals
and the tourists and i think it will be
a
economic benefit to the community in the
county so i will be supportive of this
application as well chairman
and i will propose it
thank you cancer dixon um i thought when
you said you had a disclosure you're
going to tell us you're a road racer in
the commonwealth games but
evidently not
um does anyone else have anything they'd
like to say in the debate it's council
jennings
and after yeah after covid i was going
to bring it up there a lot of people
have invested in caravans um
we need major events
um we need areas of attraction to bring
people into the district to
their money goes into it it's great for
the economy i'm more than happy to
second the recommendation
thank you very much anyone else like to
say anything
um i'll just uh there's one thing i
would like to say just to add to your
deliberations is um
we've just heard that the this site
potentially would be used during
commonwealth games um and for other
sporting events and et cetera outside of
this site
which suggests to me that it may not be
considered ancillary i'm not saying it's
not ancelery clearly there would be a
demand for both types of accommodation
um
it's just something
worth bearing in mind when you're
deliberating now we've had we've it's
we've had a proposal to grant and it's
been seconded i want to be very clear
about your reasons why you're going
against the officer's recommendations
please
on in the first one when it says that
uh whilst dallas burst and polo grounds
does not host a large events throughout
the year these are not considered
sufficient well the reason that they're
probably not holding them is because
they haven't got the accommodation for
them
so
um
you've got to start somewhere
and i think so there's a huge demand um
i say i again on the in the horsey world
i know then
my wife's always banging on about
unmounted games championships and she
goes to things like that
and uh
they end up going abroad
because there aren't sufficient places
in in the uk to host them um and those
bring in thousands of competitors
thousands in crowds and uh it would give
it was certainly a venue it would create
would have a venue where we could put
these sort of events on
thank you councillor jennings just pray
with me a second
ultimately i think what you're saying is
that this would be truly ancillary um
and would give a huge economic benefit
to the locality the residents the area
is that fair to say similar to what
we've said before
on the second point about the vehicular
act um parking that you'll be pleased to
know and i made this mistake um because
i only read the uh update on the
previous application if you look at the
update sheet you'll notice the highway
authority have removed their objections
so that has fallen away what
i made the same way
they'll be parking there
so
it's all good okay so we've got a reason
to go against officer's recommendation
i'm satisfied with it it's been proposed
and seconded so let's move to a vote so
we are um uh the application uh
reference twenty zero one three six
eight fur that's best in polar grounds
uh the proposal is to grant for the
reasons given could we please have a
show of hands for all those in favor of
granting
that is unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to grant application twenty
zero one three six eight f you alpha
margins thank you for your conditions to
be agreed to conditions of course to be
agreed with me outside of this committee
okay let's move to our final application
of the evening which is application
reference 21 0 3 8 9 8 ful that's honey
house in long compton representing
presenting officer is victoria kempton
victoria whenever you're ready over to
you
thank you
so this proposal is seeking to add 14
solar panels to honey house in the
village of long compton the application
site is identified by the black dot on
the map
the red line outlines the application
site which is located to the north of
vicarage lane the property is a modern
detached home which is arranged within a
group of
two other similar properties solar
panels would be on the south facing
elevation which would front vicarage
lane
in terms of constraints the site lies in
the cotswold area of outstanding natural
beauty and the long compton conservation
area there are also nearby listed
buildings which are outlined in red
with some coated listed buildings also
shown here
this side shows the existing and
proposed front elevation the solar
panels will be arranged over two rows of
six panels with a third row of two
panels to the left the panels would be
would project beyond the roof slope and
will be attached to rails that also have
a black appearance
so photo one shows a satellite image of
the site you can see how the property is
positioned on the highway and broadly
where views of the front roof slope
would be achieved
photo two shows the prominence of the
roof slope in terms of a property's
position to the highway and it's the
steeply pitched roof slope
you can see that the vicarage lane is a
narrow street with dry stone walls and
grass virgins either side
photos one and two show their
neighbouring properties to the left of
honey house which make up the group of
three new post-war homes
photo 3 shows view to the to the right
of the application property when taken
from vicarage lane
photo 4 shows the character of the
locality when viewed from outside honey
house in an easterly direction
and finally photo 5 shows the curses
listed building
so in conclusion given the sighting of
the nature of the solar panels the
proposal is considered to result in harm
to the landscape quality and aonb
and the significance of the conservation
area as well as setting up neighbouring
listed buildings it's therefore
recommended that this application should
be refused for the reason set out in the
office's report
one update has been listed on the update
sheet
highlighting that the unity legal
solutions document was made available
for viewing
on friday the 11th of march and that
concludes my presentation
so thank you very much would you mind
awfully putting the architect drawing on
your screen so we can all see it while
we're going through questions thank you
very much um okay if we could call
forward our first speaker on this item
which is counselor simon bing
good evening councilman thank you for
your patience this evening
councillor bing is the chairman of long
compton parish council now you'll
obviously have got an idea of what's
going to happen three minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're already press
the button in the middle and the floor
is yours
thank you mr chairman
non-constant parish council wish to
continue with their support for this
application as it will have minimal
impact on the conservation area within
the cotswold national landscape
the village of long continents sits
within aomb and is the only village
within warwickshire and the stratfor
district to wholly do so
the parish council have over many years
fought to defend the village against the
scrupulous developers and their attempts
to build and develop inappropriately
within our village
this application does not in our opinion
amount to inappropriate development and
indeed the council query as to what is
necessitate a full plumbing of
application
the parish council maintained that this
application should have been determined
under permitted development as so far as
we can see it meets the criteria
so
stratfor district stated the full
application was necessary
policy h6 of the neighborhood
development plan states that all
development must be designed to be
environmentally sustainable
it acknowledges that solar can be
installed in the village and within the
conservation area but ask for it to be
designed so as not to harm the aesthetic
it does not specifically mention
alterations to existing buildings rather
new or renovated buildings
solar by nature is going to be a degree
intrusive as it's got to be mounted on
the outside of the building there is
little or even nothing we as a parish
council can do about construction of the
panels themselves but we ask that
they're positioned at an appropriate
angle to reduce glare and have a matte
color finish so as to limit reflection
photos one and two show views on the
approach to honey house i believe this
shows the limited visual impacts of the
panels in the street scene it cannot be
that i denied as in photography that if
you're standing directly outside the
property that you will be able to see
the installation
but it is difficult to see how this can
be mitigated as by nature of the
equipment it has to be installed
externally to the property
since the adoption of the neighborhood
development plan there's been a climate
emergency declared by stratfor district
council in july 2019 where the council
pledged to take local action to
contribute to national carbon neutral
targets and aim to be carbon neutral and
stratfor district by 2030. this includes
support for renewables and schemes such
as solar together warwickshire it is to
be noted that part of the method of
achieving this is through planning and
we should be mindful of its
inclusion in the proposed south
warwickshire local plan
there's already been a precedent set
inadvertently in some cases in the
village by panels being erected with no
permission either by permitted
development or fall planning
photos four five and six show examples
of panels already existing in the
village and conservation area with all
of these visible from the footpaths and
various listed buildings and the main
a3400
the example in photo 6 was installed in
2012-13 and stratford advised that no
planning permission or lawful
development certificate was required for
this installation of solar pv
there are now some
there are now some 20 or more
installations within the village with 50
of them in the conservation area the
most recent these approved applications
within the conservation area was for the
installation of 47 ground and roof
mounted panels within the cartilage of a
listed building 30 seconds should this
committee uphold the planning office's
recommendation for refusal of this
application they'll be setting a
precedent that domestic solar
installations within the conservation
area and more specifically long compton
are not permitted development and that
they would not be acceptable before
planning either i'd urge the committee
to approve this application for the
above reasons
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for the chairman of the
parish council
no
in that case thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
okay if we can call forward our final
speakers of the evening who are sarah
and roger billings if you would like to
make your way forward
grab a desk each if you like probably
best
um now we obviously have both of you
registered are you both going to be
speaking
marvelous okay in that case you've got
an idea of the drill three minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning otherwise
whenever you're ready you press the
button in the middle and the floor is
yours
it is slightly surprising in the
circumstances of rapidly increasing
energy prices
and the declaration of the climate
emergency by the united nations that we
are here
one of the reasons why we're here is
that we took advantage of a warwickshire
solar panel scheme
and we didn't anticipate the
difficulties that we have now faced
the planning officer has talked about
the core strategy
but that in my mind is trumped by
planning law to which she doesn't refer
and i refer in that respect to the town
and country planning act general
permission development england order
2015
which deals specifically with solar
panels
it sets out the grounds
where solar panels
are not permitted in a listed building
or a conservation area none of which
apply to this application
and then deals with the grounds upon
which permission
should be granted with conditions and
those conditions are the solar panels
are permitted so far as practicable
cited so as to minimize their effect on
the external appearance of the building
they should be uh so far as practical
cited so as to minimize its effect on
the meaning of the area
and that should be capable of remove
removal as soon as reasonably practical
when no longer needed
um
the
the diagram that the officer
put up shows 14 solar panels that will
produce just under 5 000 kilowatt hours
per annum
if they were sighted on the north side
of the building that that
number of kilowatt hours would be
reduced by a half
um the
under five thousand kilowatt hours
produces
reduces our reliance on the national
grid by
uh 75 percent
uh turning to the immunity which council
of bing has described very
very forcefully
um the planning officer uh
treats vicarage lane in a very different
way than it actually is there are
sixteen properties in vicky chilean six
of which including ours are modern
none of the listed buildings are um
have a view of our property and there
are no properties opposite so the
immunity of the immediate neighbors is
not affected and the only
people who could see the solar panels
are people walking eastwards up the lane
anybody in a car would not be able to
see the solar panels at all unless they
stop to stare at them
so
for those of those on that basis i can't
see any damage to the immunity
i think thank you very much indeed mums
do you have any questions for our
applicants please
no
in that case thank you very much your
time contribution and patience this
evening
right let's move into points for
clarification for our officers i know
i've got one but does anyone else want
to go first
i'll go first then oh council dixon
you're going to go
i'll go first um
i'm sorry the uh we've heard uh from
both speakers uh speakers that um they
believe that this could be dealt with
under permission development can you
give us an idea of why you think this
shouldn't be permitted development
please
um yeah so a lawful dearness certificate
was originally submitted
it was subsequently returned
and and the full planning application
was submitted um it wasn't determined
but um it was viewed that the panels
weren't so far as practicably cited so
far as to reduce the minimize its impact
on the building and the locality
so in effect we felt they didn't meet
those conditions but the lawful
development certificate wasn't issued
so so had
in the office's view those panels been
suitably sized based et cetera then it's
possible that it could have gone through
its pure development but your view was
that it didn't meet the requirements of
business development essentially because
of that
and one at a lawful journal tip it
wasn't issued but there were concerns
raised okay
okay that's helpful i think
cancer dixon did you have a question
only in as much as
looking at the conditions regardless
mentions of the aob on top of page 63
um
it says there that
essentially it will be important to
ensure that any mitigation and adoption
measures do not adversely affect the
purpose of the aob
designation i.e conserving and enhancing
the natural beauty of the aonb
question to the officers is the built
form natural beauty or is natural
basically the hills and the landscape
not the built-fall
um it was felt that the landscape
quality was rural and it was quite um
well drawn about by the grass verges the
stone
dry stone walls and also the farmstead
at yardley farm
so does natural beauty encompass
built form natural being nature
we were looking at the landscape quality
of the aomb
council curtis please thank you thank
you and
can just be going back to the permitted
development if i
just
make sure i understand that
are you
would it have come under permitted
development
if it had been
on the north facing side of the
building or the i'm assuming this is
south facing so if it had been on this
on the other side would that have been
allowed under promised development
chairman we have to be very careful here
yeah we're deciding a different
application
or a different proposal
yeah in fairness case i was thinking the
same thing i'm quite intrigued to
understand the answer
but the reality is that's not what we're
looking at we're looking at a
proposal to put these on the south
facing side and um unless i'm much
mistaken the sun rises and sets in the
south why does it say it goes through
you know what i mean it comes from i
think i was just trying to seek
clarification on what would have been
allowed under the limit but i think your
point i think that might be something
outside of this meeting and certainly
something i'm going to um be following
up on
um anyone else who points to
clarification
no in that case let's say not to debate
who's going to kick us off
i'm going to point the finger in a
second councillor fleming
well
i'm vice chair of this climate change
panel
and
we are supposed to
encourage the use of
heat pumps and solar panels and whatever
else
um and i think in a year or two's time
maybe five
you won't find many houses that don't
have them
um and i think we have to start
somewhere and then it's the question of
striking the balance between
areas of outstanding natural beauty how
it's going to be affected where the harm
comes from from solar fat from solar
panels
um
and for me i i
i don't
i don't
form over function
seems to become a problem then because i
mean not even
taking into consideration the energy
prices rises as well everybody is
looking to do the best they can
to mitigate and offset these costs um
and i think
it's a kind of a duty almost now the way
things are going that uh from a climate
change perspective we should be looking
to use as many of these natural
resources as we can
and so from that perspective i think we
should allow it i'm not proposing just
yet but
that's where i'm coming from
thank you very much council dixon
i would propose that we actually approve
them um because uh like uh councillor
fleming there uh it is very much a
situation whereby you look at the solar
panels and you say is there any actual
harm being caused by what we're looking
at and the answer is no
did you just make a proposal to grant
yes general and your basis for that is
quite simply that you believe that these
do not cause any harm yes
okay thank you very much anyone else
counseling and service here
as we have adopted the
climate ring climate emergency
um
in principle
we have to have these things i am not
happy with the design of the panels
and uh because i know there is
alternatives
but uh people don't use them whether
they're too expensive
where you can have actually the tiles
are the same as the roof
but these stuck on top of the roof
they're not very pretty but
outweighing that
this is what we need to do
okay thank you okay thank you very much
we will need to seek a seconder for
council dixon's proposal now i would
draw your attention the fact that we
have two reasons for refusal as listed
in the
um in the officers report um i'm going
to look up
in reverse order again i'm afraid um
reason two proposal development uh by
reasonable designers titan would fail to
preserve or enhance quality of the areas
and conservation area in a setting in a
series of buildings i think what you're
saying council dixon and forgive me if
i'm i get this wrong but i think you're
saying you don't i you don't believe
there to be any harm caused by the
positioning and design layout etc of
these and therefore
um
should be allowed so that deals with
point two
um point one
um proposed development would introduce
an alien feature with a center panel
arrangement moving congressman highly
visible uh therefore causing harm to the
settings etc um again i think you're
saying there's no harm um and i think i
think and you'll tell me if i'm wrong i
think you're also saying that um
you're balancing that with the fact that
there are other examples of properties
within the location of the locality of
this prop at this this house home um
that have similar solar pv
uh on their roofs is that a fair
assessment that's a fair assessment uh
chairman and certainly i enjoyed a a
wonderful 10 mile walk last tuesday
through the cotswold aob and also lots
of properties in conservation areas
listed buildings i would have
anticipated a mellowed yellowstone with
lots of solar panels
thank you
it might work be worth also putting
something to the effect that um given
that we've had a climate emergency
uh proposed that the benefits of
having pb outweighs any harm that may
have been identified
i think it's worth adding that in
okay um now we do still need a seconder
i'm afraid so i'm going to take a second
from the floor counselor curtis would
you like to speak to that happy to
second post
marvelous thank you very much okay
unless anyone else has anything they
want to say we'll move to a vote
okay so
are you satisfied and
conditions of course didn't come to me
afterwards as usual yes okay so proposal
so the application reference
21-0-3-8-9-8-f-u-l
honey house in long compton um the
proposal is to grant uh the application
for the reasons given could i please see
a show of hands for those in favor
that is five against none abstentions
one
so committee therefore resolves to grant
application twenty one zero three eight
nine eight ful honey house and long
compton
i don't believe we have any urgent
business
we do not in that case members officers
members of the public contribute tonight
thank you very much for your time and
patience and we will see you in a couple
weeks time meetings closed
you